hey 42 here if you think it's about time
to do something to protect our planet's
ecosystems then stick around until the
end because I have an inspiring
recommendation for my friends at Planet
wild that you don't want to miss did you
know that some birds have a built-in GPS
that's so precise they can always return
to the exact same nesting spot even
after being away for years and having
traveled thousands of miles across vast
oceans and continents it's a skill we
humans would envy I once considered
calling Mountain rescue after searching
for my car in a multi- story for over 30
minutes it thoughts that birds exploit
to the Earth's magnetic field star
patterns and even o Factory cues in the
air to achieve such remarkable
navigational
Feats take the BART tailed godwit which
holds the record for the longest
non-stop flight by a bird one female
specimen was recorded flying
8,435 mil nonstop from Alaska to
Tasmania the Journey took about 9 days
without Landing once for rest or food
furthermore it did this across
completely open ocean without any
prominent landmarks to guide its way not
even a
Starbucks then there's the Arctic turn
known for having the longest migration
of any animal this small bird travels
from the Arctic to the Antarctic and
back again every year that's a journey
spanning close to 25,000 miles and
somehow they never get lost
over its 30-year lifespan your average
Arctic turn will fly enough distance to
equal going to the moon and back yet
despite this remarkable capability the
Arctic turn isn't the goat of the Aven
world hold on a minute goats don't fly
anyway what I'm trying to say is there's
a much much larger bird that is the
Undisputed Master of the
Skies to see one in Flight is to witness
one of the Miracles of Nature and then
everything about it pushes the
boundaries of what physics tells us
should be possible this winged Enigma is
found roaming the vast Arctic Ocean it's
the largest flying bird on Earth with a
wingspan that stretches well over 3 m
that's bigger than my car and my house
which is just this black box I'm trapped
in I don't even have a toilet I've spent
the past 10 years going in the garden
center across the
road anyway this bird can fly further
than most others yet it rarely beats its
wings it can live for over 60 years yet
it only breeds once every 2 years
welcome to the wonderful world the
wondering
Albatross despite its awesome size the
albatross is particularly well known for
its ability to travel spectacularly far
often flying over 600 M A Day In Search
of food and the single wandering
Albatross is expected to cover between 5
to 7 million miles in its lifetime to
put that into perspective your average
human will travel about half a million
miles in his lifetime and that includes
travel in cars trains and
airplanes when one of these Majestic
seabirds takes through the air it's
truly a sight to behold its huge Wings
fan out as it Glides with effortless
Grace rarely needing to Flat like an
astronaut on a spacewalk it appears to
defy gravity and it does something that
very few of birds can do it flies for
days even weeks on end without ever once
Landing in fact an albatross can travel
for years without returning to Solid
Ground only occasionally stopping to
land on
water it's no wonder then that these
incredible creatures have been revered
by Mariners throughout time during the
ages sail it was believed that the
wandering Albatross carried the Souls of
dead
Sailors mostly because they're known to
stalk ships for days on end gliding
effortlessly in the ship's wake it's a
rather haunting sight that has given
rise to the saying to have an albatross
around your which means one is carrying
a large burden or is
cursed but how is it that these birds
can stay aoft for so long especially
when you consider an adult weighs up to
13 kilograms the fact that I can get off
the ground in the first place is
miraculous never mind staying up there
for weeks before coming down again well
it has a few devilishly clever
adaptations that allow it to do the
seemingly impossible obviously it Mighty
wingspan of up to 3.5 m is one of its
greatest Assets Now you probably hear
that and think yeah it's basically a big
seagull but just allow me to try and
visualize how enormous these things
really are just one of its wings is as
long as I am tall and both of its wings
are the same as two fully grown men
standing on top of each other which is
highly relatable of course because we
see that all the time when we go outside
and it's not just its wings that are
Grand the albatross's Hefty body is
larger than a fully grown turkey you're
going to need a bigger oven to cook this
bad boy this is a man holding a pretty
big turkey and this is a man holding an
albatross I really shouldn't have to say
this but if you do happen to chance upon
an albatross please don't try to cook it
they're heavily protected like you'll go
to prison for life and get spanked by
David atra protected a good way of
determining how well a bird can fly is
by measuring its wing loading this is
basically the ratio of a bird's Mass to
its wing area birds with low Wing
loading are generally better Flyers
because they're able to generate more
lift the wandering Albatross has a very
low wi loading in fact it's one of the
lowest on Earth these impressive wings
are also perfectly formed with a long
slender profile they're uncannily
similar to those of an airlane when in
flight air moves faster over the top of
its wings than it does underneath
creating an area of low pressure on top
of the Wings which in turn creates lift
that keeps the bird in the air
albatrosses also have a tendon locking
mechanism that lets them lock their
wings in an extended position reducing
muscular exertion cheaters put all this
together and the wandering Albatross is
able to take off and stay in flight in
condition
so mild that most of the birds would be
grounded the albatross is also a true
Pioneer when it comes to conserving
energy they do this through a technique
called Dynamic soaring which sounds like
something the Apple marketing team came
up with this bird has special sensory
organs within its nostrils which are
able to detect subtle differences in the
wind speed basically it can smell the
wind it uses this power to constantly
ride the boundary between faster winds
up high and and slower moving air near
the water turning up into the faster air
the albatross is lifted higher then it
plummets downwards at a staggering 70
mph as it sweeps back into the slower
moving air scarily close to the water
surface the contrasting wind speed
arrests its downward momentum and then
slingshots it back up into the faster
air once again this cycle is repeated
continuously allowing it to optimally
harness the wind's energy
using Dynamic soaring the wandering
Albatross can travel vast distances
without ever flapping its wings in doing
so it exploits the energy within its
environment and expends zero of its own
it's a ballet of aerodynamics with the
vast expanse of the ocean as it
stage but what about water surely it
needs to drink while soaring for days on
end above the salty ocean well the albit
tr's bill has a specialized salt glands
these work timelessly to extract salt
from the sea water they ingest producing
vital fresh water the bird relies on for
hydration and all that excess salt is
efficiently excreted through their
nostrils if salt started coming out of
my nostrils I'd be hospitalized ASAP and
my head would be x-rayed but apparently
if you're a bird it's more of a feature
than a fault but what's really
remarkable about the wondering Albatross
is that it doesn't just fly for a long
time it lives for a long time too how
long well in 1956 a mature L Albatross
was ringed to keep a track of it she was
named wisdom and she must have been one
smart cookie indeed because she was
found again in 2021 hatching yet another
chick making her at least 70 years old
that makes wisdom the oldest confirmed
wild bird in the world
world to put that into perspective a
sparrow lives for about 3 years a mighty
bald eagle lives for about
25 but albatrosses frequently survive
over 60 years out in the wild and the
wild is a bloody terrifying Place some
say the albatross could live up to 100
years but that's yet to be verified
looking at the wondering Albatross it's
clear that it's built for survival they
have incredibly low metabolic rates
meaning they need to eat less food and
can spend longer in the air without
stopping for a snack which comes in
handy because it's been known to travel
up to 5,000 miles in one hunting trip
just to find squid to feed to its young
that's the equivalent of me flying from
London to Los Angeles just to grab some
sushi for lunch yet despite these
fascinating adaptations and incredible
Feats of endurance one of the most
enchanting moments in a life of an
albatross comes when they they do touch
ground which they might only do once
every few years and what brings them
back to dry land you ask sex obviously
it's always sex suddenly the islands
dotting the Arctic Ocean become the
stage for a mesmerizing dance both males
and females engage in a series of
coordinated movements they pre each
other they do a bit of fencing with
their bills then they make a selection
of really [__] weird sounds in each
other's faces
specifically they're known to perform
sky calling where they Point their bills
at the sky and make a chilling screaming
sound which kind of sounds like a
thousand people burning in the fires of
Mordor an albatross can sometimes caught
its potential lover for hours but it's
important to be picky because once a
bond is established Albatross are
monogamous and they remain faithful to
that partner for life
which sounds impressive but then you
remember it spends most of its time on a
seabound solo stago doing some assaults
thousands of miles from home for years
at a
time but even in their moments of
solitude when their mate might be
thousands of miles away some believe
they stay connected through the wind
people mostly hippies say an albatross's
partner can hear its calls even on the
other side of the planet poetic notion
that is obviously complete bollocks and
yet for all their majesty and Marvel the
wandering Albatross is vulnerable their
primary threats come from long line
fishing and plastic pollution these
birds often mistake plastic for prey
ingesting it and feeding it to their
chicks and the consequences can be
lethal similarly they frequently find
themselves at the end of long line
fishing hooks and drown watching such a
formidable Beast perish in such a cruel
and unfair way is a very sad thing
indeed the wonderful wondering Albatros
has inspired countless stories Legends
and songs over the centuries they remind
us that no matter how difficult life may
seem and no matter how impossible the
challenges that lay in our paths we can
always take a moment and a at the
delicate dance of a beautiful bird as it
soes across the ocean proving that
limits are made to be
[Music]
broken thanks for watching if you want
to do your part to save the albatross
and other incredible animals on the
verge of Extinction then check out
Planet wild they're an Environmental
Protection Organization funding
ecosystem restoration projects that are
preserving our nature and Wildlife they
carry out a new rewilding Mission every
month and what I love about planet wild
is their complete transpar y they
document their work in a monthly video
report on their YouTube channel so you
can actually see the difference they're
making in their latest video you can see
how they're protecting Dolphins from
Mass tourism whilst also learning so
much about them as a supporter you get
to see your impact firsthand via YouTube
and the planet Wild app I support Planet
wild because I want to make a direct
impact on preserving nature and I
believe in taking small scale but
noticeable action so if you want to join
a growing Community making a real
difference protecting our EOS systems
check out Planet wild and consider
becoming a supporter I will cover the
first month of your subscription for the
first 200 people signing up with my Code
42 and if you want to get to know them
better first then check out their latest
mission video on their YouTube channel
big thanks to Planet wild for sponsoring
this video and please don't forget to
check them out because what they're
doing is genuinely
amazing